it was all smiles when the new coalition
of Social Democrats and Christian
Democrats was formed in December but the
honeymoon bliss soon gave way to
bickering the previous coalition saw
similar marital mal content of course a
bunch of buns was among the kind of
remarks being thrown about what are the
electorate make of the new grand
coalition future they know they got off
to a bad start there needs to be more
effort from both sides what's this
dhamaka honest water took far too long
for them to come to an agreement over
certain policies that opiates hadley
really been so wrong we need to be more
open and give them a chance in batch
oscillating I don't know the best thing
would be for them to quit and have fresh
elections spacer for thirty-nine percent
of the electorate the new coalition is
more divided than the previous one and
thirty-four percent say relations are
just as bad only eighteen percent say
the government is a harmonious one still
the grand coalition does have four years
to learn to live together
you